how's it going Wolfgang today we have
some big news that could possibly impact
Avengers 4 before we get into it just
another reminder about the giveaway I'm
doing I'll be giving away a few copies
of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray if
you'd like to enter the giveaway all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like the video and comment below with
your favorite superhero I did a video
not too long ago and I mentioned a
voodoo viewing party so voodoo is a
media company and during their viewing
party they had the opportunity to be
able to ask the rusev Brothers anything
that they wanted on Twitter and get
responses from them I told you that I'd
be doing more videos on some of the
questions they were asked and some of
the answers that they gave and today's
gonna be on a really big one
today is going to be about red skull so
during the viewing party one person
asked now that the soul stone has been
taken is Red Skull free to leave for
mere check out the response from the
reso brothers they said red skull is
free to leave armor and he is also free
to pursue his desire for an infinity
stone so right off the bat this answer
is just crazy because it seemed like
from infinity war Red Skull was destined
to stay and warm air forever
so Novelis Gamora daughter of Thanos we
all think that at first
[Music]
but that is clearly not the case let's
dissect their answer for a second
because to me this seems like they're
telling us something because the first
part of this tweet is all you really
needed to answer the question because if
he's not involved in Avengers 4 then
it's really a simple question with a
simple answer his Red Skull free to
leave or mere yes Red Skull is free to
leave for mere but they gave us more
than that they gave us the second part
and he is also free to pursue his desire
for an infinity stone that is oddly
specific pursue his desire for an
infinity stone not the Infinity stones a
single Infinity stone why throw that in
there if it means nothing
you wouldn't it's unnecessary so I think
they may be hinting at something here
it's clear that whatever sort of curse
was on Red Skull that kept him with the
soul stone on Vermeer is broken it's
done and Red Skull can leave but the
question is what did he learn on Vermeer
did the soul stone speak to him he was
clearly connected to it somehow he knew
what it needed to be obtained managed me
here guiding others to a treasure
I cannot possess so has he somehow
learned what he needs to do to obtain an
infinity stone and harness it it seems
that logically the answer to this would
be yes and that single Infinity stone
that he desires would of course be the
space stone which was the tesseract
there's a few ways they could take this
with Avengers 4-1 keep him as a bad guy
he's the same Red Skull that we knew
from before the same one that fought
Captain America and he's after an
infinity stone again for power too and
this is not very likely because it kind
of defeats the purpose of Red Skull
being able to leave form here now but
that is that we could possibly see him
back in time somewhere we know Avengers
4 is going to have time-travel involved
in it so we could obviously see him back
in time somewhere but this has nothing
to do with him being able to leave
vermeer now but number three would be
quite interesting and that is that he
would become
a good guy well sort of villains
typically do not like when other
villains are better than them so Red
Skull is finally free to leave for mare
he can do whatever you want now and then
thanassis snap half of the universe is
gone
Thanos caused it not to mention Diana's
has all of the Infinity stones and the
Russo brothers seem to have made it
clear that Red Skull desires a specific
Infinity stone so he will have to get it
from Thanos but he obviously realizes
how powerful fan OHS is and realizes
that he cannot do it by himself I
ignored my destiny once
I cannot do that again even
for you so he goes and looks for his old
buddy Cappy obviously red skull has
information that the Avengers could use
on the Infinity stones so they could
possibly team up to take down Thanos the
enemy of my enemy is my friend and last
but certainly not least at number four
is that
Thanos could actually seek out Red Skull
we already know that obtaining the soul
stone and accomplishing his snap cost
him everything specifically his
stepdaughter Gamora
who he loves very much perhaps there's a
way to get her back
and perhaps Red Skull knows so that is
what the Russo brothers had to say about
Red Skull being able to leave for mere
and seeking out an infinity stone and
those were four different ways that Red
Skull could appear in Avengers 4 what do
you all think about my theories and what
theories do you have of your own be sure
to let me know in the comments below and
again another reminder about the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you